the president of the united states
incited an armed insurrection against
america
the gleeful desecration of the u.s
capitol
which is the temple of our of our
american democracy
and the violence targeting congress are
horrors that will forever
stain our nation's history instigated by
the president
of the united states that's why it's
such
a stain in calling for this seditious
act president has committed an
unspeakable assault
on our nation and our people
i joined the senate democratic leader in
calling on the vice president
to remove this president by immediately
invoking the 25th
amendment if the vice president and
cabinet do not act
the congress may be prepared to move
forward with impeachment
that is the overwhelming sentiment of my
caucus
and the american people by the way
justice will be done to those who
carried out these acts
which were acts of sedition and acts of
cowardice
to those whose purpose was to deter our
responsibility
you have failed you did not divert the
congress from
our solemn constitutional purpose
to validate the overwhelming election
of joe biden and kamel harris as
president and vice president
of the united states despite the
desecration of our capital
we upheld and in front of the country
and the world the bedrock
principle that the people are sovereign
and that they hold the power
to choose their leaders through the
ballot
rejecting this attempted coup on the
part of president trump
and his supporters accountability is
also needed for republicans in congress
who
promoted the extreme conspiracy theories
that provoked the violence encouraged
the mob
and who after desecration of the capital
went back to the house floor and
continued to push the falsehoods
and underpinned this assault
that underpinned this assault on our
democracy these republicans abdicated
their oath of office that was taken just
three days prior
to protect the american people and to
support and defend the constitution of
the united states